hello and welcome everyone to active inference lab to the guest stream the
active inference guest stream number 2.1 on march 18 2021 featuring Dimitris
Bolis and this is going to be a really awesome discussion on a wide variety of topics
so i'll just pass it to Dimitris to introduce himself and take it away we're going to have a presentation first and
then we'll be documenting questions from the live chat so please drop any thoughts or questions in there and then
we'll have a discussion after this presentation so thanks again for coming on the stream we really appreciate the
time and please take it away hello everybody
um i'm very happy being here thank you very much the organizers for um organizing and presenting such an
interesting series of short seminars so today
i will like to present you a work that we have been doing
primarily the last six years in munich
in collaboration with leonard zilbach and his group in max planck and
basically the title i interact therefore i am human becoming in and through social
interaction is the title of my phd dissertation
that i was presented last year about this month
so for anybody that would like more
details at the end of the talk they would always go back to the document it's already
published in researchgate and there you can find also the
already first papers that came out from this work but more
are coming in the way in the next few months so
i'll start by presenting the outline of this presentation so first we will go
through the theoretical work which consists of the dialectical and human
hypothesis and the dialectical missed human hypothesis which
both focus and emphasize the importance of social interaction
in human becoming across various contexts from and various scales from evolution to
cultural development and psychopathology then importantly we will discuss
concrete empirical methodologies with regards to how we can put into the
formal test this kind of hypothesis and which we
call to personal psychophysiology because this work tries to extend
the traditional psychophysiology work in the social domain so
we will see how based on hyperscanning research for example
we integrate different streams of studying
for monitoring recording and analyzing
and data in high resolution from multiple people at the same time that they are able to interact in
real time then we will go through the empirical work and the first two studies
and which is about the interpersonal achievement in real-time social interactions and
especially through js and second about the interpersonal
arms of humans in real life social relationships and this is with regards to artistic traits
and interpersonal similarity and fourth we will discuss
some scientific and societal implications of this work and
we will briefly conclude so the theoretical work is based on
two main pillars that's a philosophical
framework developed across many centuries going back to ancient
years in ancient greece and also ancient china
or india and we will go through more details later
but this was developed further in more modern times in especially in france and germany
and also we lean upon heavily the bayesian brain
hypothesis and especially the framework of predictive processing and active inference
so i guess most of the people here might be already familiar with these frameworks
but i would like to go through a simple example um just to make clear the
practical implications of this kind of frameworks
so let us imagine um lady waking up
late for her work and so she cannot decide what to wear for
going to work but based on her previous experience as she lives
in the south part of greece in crete she believes that
most probably the weather will be good and sunny so she decides to go out without carrying
an umbrella or a coat however these days is unlikely
so instead contrary to her predictions
the weather was rainy and that day she got wet the second day even though she
believed that the probability for raining might be five percent so she increased her the
probability her beliefs about the probability of reigning and however she still
decided not to carry an umbrella this continues for a week
where she finally have come to come to believe that the
probability of raining even in this period in this place was 90 percent and decided
to carry an umbrella so we see here how she gradually updated her beliefs based
on the evidence that he observed in real life and gradually
let us imagine another illustrative example the same lady goes for vacations
to japan and she again is laid to go out and she
has not decided whether she needs to carry an umbrella if you're not based on rumors in this
um time she again believes that the weather will be good so she's slightly dressed
however again she's again unlucky and the weather is raining
so already um in this case the lady for example
in this for this from the second day already she believes that the probability of framing
will be 90 so we see here example uh regarding the
updating of the weather beliefs why is that happening here from ebay
asian perspective one could argue that in this case that her beliefs were
formed quickly through social rumors they were more less confident so more
susceptible into change when faced with contradictory evidence
that's a very important factor in the base and brain hypothesis
i will not go through the mathematical details but with this very simple
simplifying examples we examine two cardinal aspects of such accounts
namely the updating of beliefs through integrating
a prior knowledge and new data
and also we examine the learning rate of
this procedure which is thought of as a
um a weighted precision prediction error which means
that the more confident we are about our previous beliefs
the less likely we are to update them in phase of contradictory
information so this framework
has gained much attention over the last years first because as we see we can it's
a useful in examining various
real life scenarios and put them into formal equations
and models which can be formally examined and
tested against one another
so of course the outline of this account that we've drawn so far
it's rather simplistic so in this case we only examined this scenario that one
person observes passively the world and
their only choice is to update their beliefs
according to what they observe so these scalpers have
mentioned resembles in some aspects the old plato's cave allegory where humans
were nothing else that than prisoners from the whole for their whole lives in
a deep cave where they never experienced the outer world and their only experience
about their environment was through projections on a wall through siders of
the real objects that are reflected on the world in front of them so this we can imagine um
in a way humans or other organisms exam experiencing the world
in a manner like that as we have specific sensory organs
where information from the world is projected and we
selectively experience the reality around us of course this is
just a partial image of what is happening one
right away can think of a second avenue of
achievement between the organism and the environment so as we said it first said the organism tries to
minimize prediction error through perception and learning by adjusting their own beliefs to the environment but
of course an organism can also update their beliefs through action so that they selectively
transform and some the world in a way that it conforms to their initial beliefs
so so this is i con constitutes a more comprehensive
account of organismic life and especially human life but
we will argue in line with other recent accounts in this talk that this is
account is still not enough on its own because it considers individual organisms um
out of context out of their social context and especially with regards to humans out of the
crucial cultural context as well in our effort to embed this um kind of
accounts we have leaned on um the electrical approach
which as i am we saw before um it consists in constitutes a school of
thought which goes back to ancient years and continues until
these years always enrich in different historical contexts so the importance of this
framework is that it emphasizes unity of phenomena
it does neglect inner contradictions and emphasize movement of phenomena or
change and so a situation of crisis or radical changes
it doesn't seem to this account as problematic but also as chances of
updating and embracing so this kind of accounts try to overcome
dichotomies such as the organism and the environment the individual in the collective
or as we will see in our work even a patient versus their cultural
context special emphasis is given
not only in intra-level processes but also between level processes across
various temporal scales so this account goes against
both dualism and reductionism as it tries to examine
phenomena in the wholeness but without
metaphysically assuming independent levels of reality
um traditionally sciences
for good reasons also for lack of tools have
focused on specific levels of description of reality such as
for example the physical or biological level or the psychophysiological level
this kind of studies have provided important insights
however when examined um isolated in single levels we will argue
it doesn't provide the whole picture of complex phenomena such as psycho
sociocultural or psychiatric phenomena so in this
work we have argued that even deploying simple
research paradigms will be crucial to try to
probe and monitor processes that live on different levels
of description based on this
assumption we have reviewed human becoming as a dialectic of internalization and
externalization and more precisely connected the internalization processes
to predictive processing which as we saw from our examples
is the mechanism of updating our own beliefs in order to
conform to the environmental regularities and we connected the externalization
processes and especially collective externalization processes to active inference
which is a process of co-regulating the outer world and especially the social world
according to our inner beliefs but also according to our
collective inner beliefs
and one can see a human becoming as a human with a world
both physical world and others so
here we see how we can how organisms such animals or humans
try to regulate the [Music] the world both physical and social world
and by acting on the world so for example in this case
this little animal holds the ball against the gravity first that means that already
in an embodied way captures the physical dynamics of earth with
but also acts against the social influence for example here an attempt to
from somebody taking the ball so we see
human becoming as a dielectric human in in a large scale as a
nutshell as an interpersonal we say that interpersonal statistical regularities say multi-scale
hierarchical models on an individual level and vice versa and this can happen from across
different scales from philogenesis culture and donald genesis
to everyday learning decision making perception and even so-called
automatic interceptive process our
perspective draws heavily on a vegotian perspective who have famously declared
the claim that through others we become ourselves
so in order to further illuminate this view let us imagine a
simple um example let us imagine a little baby
that feeling hungry as
their interceptive systems is out of balance and tries to reach for food however the
motor repertoire of such a human being
it's not developed yet fully
and so this baby is unable to reach for food on
its own so what happens is that usually the caregiver
will notice such kind of behavior and it and it will try to satisfy that
for example by placing the food closer to the baby
so in this case we see we can even imagine how this kind of interpersonal
relation between the caregiver and the baby results may result in a
internalization of in a symbolic level of this kind of
processes so the baby both
across evolutionary and development might come to realize that when
extending the hands of the index finger
and calls for attention pointing to a specific object that they
need so we see how an interpersonal relationship based on
natural needs for survival might end up in internalization
of in on a symbolic level
so here that's that example is important uh in our talk because this illustrates
how a collective level a level of description for of process between people
might be transformed into single brains and single bodies processes
and actually makes us what we are becoming and that is humans you know
growing up and these kind of accounts
are very much in line with the framework of an activism and especially
the account of participatory instance making which has focused a lot
on the fundamental role of social interactions and um
both from individual sense making which is always affected by
coordination dynamics while we are in embedding social interactions or the way
to join sense making how that means how we jointly with others
make sense of the world
however this kind of account might seem
theoretical so now here we will
ask the question how can we apply this kind of ideas and why is it
even important to reflect um on these processes and
whether the these processes lie on a lower level of descriptions or
collective levels or between so to illustrate an example we will
use autism as a paradigm example and
we will try to illustrate how these ideas can be concrete and
concretely put into practice so autism spectrum condition has been
described as a pervasive developmental condition which is characterized by difficulties in social interaction and
communication as well as restricted interested interests and all sensory behaviors so that's the
traditional typical definition of autism spectrum
conditions and some predominant approaches so far he focused on
difficulties or so-called impairments of theory of mind these theories
describe autism as a condition that individuals have problems with
understanding the intentions um or beliefs of other people so there is
also there are also alternative hypotheses such as the social motivation hypothesis
which claims that people with autism have usually diminished
social motivation to interact with others so in this case they might lack opportunities in gaining
[Music] more accomplish abilities we see
also weak central coherence account
and or executive dysfunction which is refers to more individual
characteristics of individuals or autistic individuals such as
difficulties with planning or paying more attention to global
to sorry local information rather than global information and we also see broken mirror neuron
hypotheses which emphasize the difficulty of autism
of autistic people when it comes to empathizing
and more recently we have computational approaches such as the aberrant or
inflexible precision updating which grounded in predictive processing
accounts and they claim that autism might result from
aberrant way of updating precision and
more concretely regulating the updating of beliefs as we saw
by integrating previous previously gained experience with in phase of
newly incoming information so we see here that
this type of accounts they are either more social accounts right like the
theory of mind social motivation broken middle neuron account or even the upbring precision updating when it comes
to the social world however and even in this case
where others are into into the frame
the condition is exclusively attributed and examined within single
individuals and especially single brains so
the most predominant approaches of autism focus on individuals and try to diagnose
or even treat such conditions by paying attention primarily on the individual
so for example in research it's common to
identify two groups for example one so-called neurotypical or non-autistic group
and one autistic group and then by deploying a specific paradigm
we try to identify traditionally differences in behavioral patterns or brain function and this kind
of paradigms then attribute this kind of differences in a
deficient functioning of the autistic
so however as we will argue here and in line with an interactive and subjective
turn in research of psychopathology and specifically autism
and we will see how by including
real-time social interactions and social relationships
we can expand this focus from individual brains to the process between people
and especially in communication so this line of
work would suggest that it's not enough to identify two different groups of people
like neurotypical and autistic people but already by beginning examining diets
of people or groups of people one can naturally see that we are
we have a variable here at least three different broad categories of
partners for example in our case we have neurotypical partners we have autistic partners but
we have also mixed partners which means consisting of
at least one autistic individual and at least one neurotypical individual so in this case
our hypothesis has been that at least in certain levels especially in
the experiential level the autistic individuals
will entertain similar levels of smoothness interactive smoothness as the neurotypical partners whereas mixed
diets might appear in certain levels interacting less efficiently
and if that hypothesis is correct then
one can see that the um the deficiency doesn't lie in the
individual brain of the autistic but at least partially
we can locate it in process between individuals this is very much in line with the double empathy problem
of damian milton who have argued that the authority of exactly of the
autism condition does not lie in the individual but it comes from mismatches
of social abilities of expectations
one can imagine even probing this framework further
by not necessarily de-otomizing people in autistic or non-artistic or
any other category we can imagine but rather examining
such traits on a continuum and then examining the
interaction smoothness based um on the distance of people in a space
of conditions rather than in a single dimensional spectrum of conditions
later we will see how this can be operationalized so as
after this illustrative example as we already mentioned the last decade
um especially but also before through [Music]
more sociological accounts we have seen an endless objective turn
in the study of autism and other conditions and just give a few examples um
for example the dumpling of the problem has argued that social difficulties um in autism
arises two-way complication and that does not reside in single brains
but also um as we saw an activist and participatory since making accounts have
claimed that atypicalities can be viewed as a different way of making sense of others
and interacting with the world or second person neuropsychiatry
perspectives have claimed that social difficulties are more likely or even only
manifest themselves in real-time social interactions whereas more passive scenarios
might be less problematic clinically
um finally a part of this work the electronics of human hypothesis has
bring together in the subjective approaches and predictive process and processing approaches have reviewed in
conditions such as autism but autism but also other conditions not as a disorder
of the individual but rather as a cumulative in the personal misadhumen
so in a nutshell interpersonal mix achievement can be thought of as
disturbances of the dynamic and reciprocal unfolding of an interaction across multiple time scales
resulting in increasingly divergent prediction and interaction styles or
patterns and vice versa as we saw the hypothesis
aligned with other accounts holds clear predictions and so before we start
experimenting empirically we made concrete hypotheses in terms of the
interactions which we suggested that interactions within
homogeneous and non-tuned diets are expected to
and i'm sorry in human diets are expected to appear smoother compared to heterogeneous diets or non-tuned diets
we will see later what we mean by socialization and homogeneous or heterogeneous
importantly we see here an interplay between levels of description between the subjective
communicative gap and individual prediction and interaction styles which might appear
diverse across people of different conditions and here we see how an initially their
subjective cognitive gap can result in increasing individual
diverse diverse prediction interaction styles and how as
we have people that have formed um diverse social expectations about each
other how this can increa result increasing such an intersubjective community gap across various scales one
can imagine for example at the scale of a dialogue and
for example let's say i i start with making a comment that another person might take as insulting
then the other person replies to me back in an aggressive manner and then i'm sorry i'm starting
feeling uh angry and this can escalate potentially in a
major missed human in the scale of just few seconds or few minutes especially
this can happen between people for example that have cultivated distinct
systems of beliefs for example different cultures and they don't didn't have a chance to
get to know other systems of beliefs
this in the case of autism for example this one can imagine that this kind of
interactions might play out during across development so a child
in a school for example that other children are not informed about
different communication styles might isolate exclude and isolate this child
so and forcing this child to
develop with a decreased level of social interaction we see this not only
with in terms of autism also about with regards to other
social communicative differences um people are can be excluded for example
immigration populations in new places might be excluded initially
based on this kind of in the subjective community of gaps
so in our case going back to autism we will try to personalize the homogeneity of
diets of partners as a similarity of
in terms of autistic traits we can which we can measure with standard questionnaire tests
and we will operationalize in our experiments the smoothness of an
interaction based on the perceived friendship quality again through questionnaires for example
but later we will see how we can extend this work in a more fine-grained time scale for
example in at a scale of milliseconds when it comes to
interpersonal gaze behavior or interpersonal facial expression behavior
so our experimental methodology takes the form of two personal
psychophysiology or collective psychophysiology which tries to expand the
study of psychophysiological phenomena into the social collective domain
here our first study on the interpersonal human in real time social interactions
make use of this methodology which is grounded in second person neuroscience accounts
which which claim that in real-time social interaction
brain or other processes might be fundamentally different than
simpler passive social social passive observational scenarios so when we
really interact with another in real time for example in the discussion these accounts um
hypothesize that our brain will function in different qualitatively different and quite quantitatively
different way as when we just sit back and observe others
without the opportunity to feedback to each other we'll not go
in detail and hear about the brain process as we in our studies here we'll see
mainly behavioral results so also our two-person psychophysiology
framework is based on previous work of the last
couple of decades such as for example fmri or eeg
hyperscanning here you see one of the seminal works of gigan duma which
connected two eeg systems into into the same computer in order to at the same time
examine the brain function of two people while interacting
[Music] through um hand movement
also other later works such as work from wikileaks or
hikokoi have examined phenomena for example from deeper in the
brain with the use of fmri hyperscanning or across development
our two-part setup is looks like that so i'll not go here also
in detail i just want to make clear that our system is deploys different several different
recording modalities and in a completely symmetrical way in
order to make sure that we in prefer synchronicity we can monitor the
individual processes of two or more people from decision making to eye movements
and fascial expressions and brain function all at the same time so that we can interrelate
first processes of different modalities within the same person like for how decision making is
connected to our emotional processing or facial expressions
and how we our brain function modulates eye movements
and and back how and how perceived social information modulates brain function and
second to interrelate um the multi modal processes of individuals
with one another so how my visual information for example
influence your behavior and how your behavior influences me in a closed loop
so in reality our setup looks like that so two persons are invited in
the lab and they solve uh simple visual tasks
while they are able to communicate and interact through a micro camera at the center of the
screen which deploys the face of the other person
in so here in our first experiment the important manipulation was that
while people were able to communicate in real time like in skype manner
in half of the game people could not communicate in real time because we
replayed the part of the video of the previous interaction without letting people know
so in our game the two people thought that they always communicated in real
time however contrary to their
perception in half of the game they really communicated but in half of the game they just observe the the video of the
other person and so in this case we will be able to decent angle
quantitatively the impact of the social interaction dynamics even in the absence of conscious
interpretation of the situation so here we can see our two main
conditions of the live video feed where allows the two people to form essentially one system uh
interacting system and in the other case we have two distinct systems uh cognitive systems we just
observe um recorded videos of the other without knowing
our game looks like that it's based on a similar work of bajador baramin and
colleagues in london it's a psychophysiological
task where we ask people to identify the old
object on the screen without knowing that there is no odd object object on the screen so
because we have four possible possibilities left right up or down
we expect just a 25
chance of co-occurrence [Music]
uh between the decisions of the two persons so whatever whatever weeks we
observe above and beyond 25
um in a statistical significant manner we can attribute
just on the dynamics of the social interaction because every other piece of information
remains the same for the two people except for the dynamics of their
interaction three days so for example here you can see case one
and we have covered the eyes of people for privacy reasons but here we can you can see how people
in real time even when they don't see the face the whole face of the other person they are synchronized and happy
and interacting together at the same time look here for example how
perfectly aligned is even their [Music] facial expressions
the same here we cannot see the eyes but the same will see about the eyes the same happens people tend to follow each
other eyes but let's see now a second place where people in the same game the same day after a
few seconds they played a version of the game where without knowing one person
see only the video of the eyes of the other person so in this case you see people start being confused like why
don't you follow me as i follow you etc so this creates a missed achievement
an artificial missed achievement where people naive about our experimental control cannot attribute
to our manipulations but
as we saw a few questions they had good through psychological interpretations like the other person was
bored or tired at some points of the game here for example
we can see how the interpersonal interpersonal achievement play out in
the behavioral domain and especially here in how the two gay traces of the two
persons coincide and follow each other like independent interacting
little creatures and here are formal results
um based on our analysis of the gauge trace here we can see we formed three
experimental conditions we have one pseudo condition where we suffered diet from different days
and we see that their gas coordination the green is the lowest then we see that when people really
observe the other person in the room the yellow the sorry the orange distribution we see that we have an
increased um yes coordination metric but what really made the
difference is when people are allowed to really interact with each other we see that their gaze trace was
synchronized the most very interestingly we observe exactly the same pattern
um in terms of of a completely different
level of description and this is the decision making alignment again here we see that when
we analyze data from people of different partners we see that indeed
the probability of agreeing on the same object was around 25 we see here the
green distribution centers around 25 then we see that the orange distribution already on the uh
about the observational scenario is slightly increased but what was highly increased was the
decision-making alignment in the real-time social interaction scenario also this is reflected in the
interrelationship between the two modalities we see here both in the online and offline
conditions we see and statistical interactions between the
two modalities so the more the gauge coordinate the higher the gas coordination the higher was the
decision-making alignment and we also see that the the in the case of real-time social
interaction this interrelationship appeared stronger
also another interesting finding is that the confidence
difference between the two conditions was significant so people without even knowing that there was two different
conditions appear more confident about their own choices
depending in the real-time social interaction situations as opposed to the
offline or social observation scenarios so here we see how the social interaction dynamics
even when we don't we are not aware of them consciously
influences us phenomenologically and even to the level
of our confidence about our own decision making
so finally we also see a relationship between gaze coordination and the
perceived level of collaboration so the more people
follow each other days the more likely we are to report a higher level of satisfaction in
collaboration so
we're going to start these two where we examine the personal
misachievement and this time in real life social relationships here we try to
move our empirical studies outside of the lab in the real world
without performing any manipulation just by collecting and
registering the experiences the real life experiences of
people in the real world so here we started the link more concretely between this similarity
of autistic traits and friendship ratings along a continuum and for that to this end we invited
pairs of friends to complete questionnaires about their individual autistic traits and the quality of their friendship
without being able to communicate their replies of course to each other
then we analyzed this data that we gathered from 144 neurotypical adults
which formed 72 same-sex diets of friends
which whose friendship duration varied a lot from 3
months to 30 years and their meeting frequency again was diverse from a few times per year to
daily in the ages of fatherhood from 19 years old to 50
years old and in a balanced in terms of sex
sample of participants here we see the distributions of the main
[Music] measures of our study friendship quality friendship duration
autistic traits and autistic traits mismatch which is simply the difference of
my autistic traits versus your autistic traits in a given diet of friendship
this study was recently probably so people that are interested can go
back and see all the details so in a nutshell
what we find here is that um whereas individual autistic traits were
related with the friendship quality in line with
previous studies in our study of real life social relationships this
apparent relation ship was not significant statistically at least in the
amount of our sample size as we see and it only appeared the same
very weak interrelationship what was more interesting was the
as hypothesized the interrelationship between the mismatch
of artistic traits and the friendship quality and here we see that the more the
mismatch of autistic traits so the more different the two people were in a given diet the less satisfied appeared
in their in their friendship um is and this result was irrespective
of friendship duration aids sex or even the average they had the codistic traits
similar observations we found with regard to
friendship duration we found no interrelation in the relationship at all between friendship duration and
individual autistic traits in our sample but we indeed found um
an interrelationship between mismatch of autistic traits and french duration
so the key constituents of friendship quality that contributed to this kind of results were interpersonal acceptance closeness
and help so
based on our empirical observations um we can speculate and suggest the future
directions of research relevant work which will examine the
dialectical phenomena between different levels of analysis from the collective to the
individual and back so for example in this case we can speculate that potentially potential higher
interpersonal achievement between people might lead to smoother social interactions
which intent might transform our interaction in with another person more in
in a more rewarding form so we are more happy to communicate with this specific person and these
have been found to enhance even interpersonal attraction about each other and this attraction might increase the
motivation to interact further and the more frequent interaction with the other might boost interaction with
success and this interaction success might contribute back to higher interpersonal
human of course such a process it's a simplification and more experiments
um are needed to examine the different stages of such a
dialectical procedure in real life
so in our discussion i will examine some limitations and future direction of
our work first we can
and should measure more fine-grain mechanisms in a more clearly modulatory
experiment using hyperscanning and computational modeling
in order to tap into more detailed mechanisms of this kind of phenomena
also in the future we can deploy unmediated face-to-face
interactions such as real life monitoring of verbal and touching behavior
we should examine also more heterogeneous examples of the population for example mixed gender
population or cross-cultural diets and groups or even
groups of the same culture but of different socio-economic background or educational background
further scales of social interaction dynamics can be incorporated and here we
drawing on the dielectric human hypothesis
we suggest to continue with longitudinal tracking of two-person and
collective psychophysiology so that we also monitor the
development of such kind of achievement or misachievement across several years
in real life scenarios also clinical studies are needed in
order to examine this kind of hypothesis across
as we saw different types of diets or groups which would include autistic or other conditional
diets neurotypical ones and but also mixed ones
indeed we have already started in collaboration with wikileaks and takashiko koike
to deploying such hyperscanning studies in order to tap into their brain mechanisms
using both aeg hyperscanning and fmri hyperscanning hopefully
shown in japan when the situation stabilizes
in terms of the condemn also we at the same time analyze facial
expressions between two people and here we also already saw how two people
might synchronize in facial expressions when they interact in real time
a hypothesis goes in similar lines as with with what we saw before
so before concluding i would like also to enjoy a sketch of our future
computational plans here we have on a paper which is called beyond one
base and brain we have suggested that we should go beyond individual bayesian modeling of
the isolated brain towards collective models which will capture
both intra-subjective beliefs and intra-subjective confidence of beliefs
but also inter-subjective coupling factors here in this
paper from 2007 uh we were based on previous
work of donnie zoe and chris mattis which
is developed around the metabase and two-level [Music]
computational scheme
for concluding if we should mention that
especially in the last two three years uh more and more evidence um appear in in favor of
a viewing psychopathology as an interpersonal misadvent and not
only as exclusively disorder of the brain
and if this evidence at least in certain levels of description holds valid and robust one
can imagine that apart from examining
and treating individuals
and diagnosing individuals we can [Music]
pass through more comprehensive social approaches where we will
at the same time treating an individual with a certain condition but at the same time we will also inform the society
about these conditions um so in a way our approach point
towards not showing only persons with a specific condition into the incidental
norm of our cultural context but
tries to foster an interpersonal meeting
at the middle if you will so for example of course we don't suggest by deploying for example
from psychopharmacology in the general population but for example with a
informational campaigns in schools and we indeed
suggest a tuning of social expectations of or enrichment if you will
in order to provide a more inclusive society
for everybody also our approach uh all um points towards
a treatment of interaction as such in line with for example participations making
suggestions where we envision modern schools for example
that would care about tuning the medium of communication between people for example
in a previous work we have suggested developing educational systems
mediated through computers or even social robotics or serious gaming between two individuals
which could alleviate some initial social pressures and allow people to communicate smoother
in the first steps of development of communication between two
people as um
we have seen before i am in this scheme we can
simply observe our suggestion is trying to treat this kind of
interpersonal mis-achievement between two individuals or autistic and one narcissistic for example which might
diverge if left unnoticed by treating not only the autistic
individual but also the neurotypical individual and also
trying to take care of the interaction tuning between them but
in a way that at the end will result we are left with a tuned diet and not tuned
individuals so what we hear is that people can communicate smoothly and satisfactory with each other and
we don't care about identifying ideal normal
against which other [Music]
types styles of communication should conform
so in this work concluding taking together we have
argued that social interaction does indeed matter across various contexts
and time scales and in fact we even consider the question of social
interaction as the fundamental philosophical question and our argument here is a
generally existential one as without social interaction we cannot even exist
as humans thank you very much
for your kind attention and i would like also to thank several people that have collaborated
with us across the last five six years in order to for us to accomplish a
vast amount of experiments of about 400
people and especially my academic advisor leonard zilbach
who assisted me in the journey of the last six years
thank you very much i would be happy now to receive any question and
happily discuss excellent maybe you can unshare your
screen and we can take it from there well thanks for this really amazing talk that was
truly something special and we got a bunch of questions maybe you can unshare and then you'll return to regular mode
excuse me you can unshare your screen in the jitsu yes yeah so
um for everybody who's watching live we have a bunch of questions already and you can ask more and i'll just ask them
just in the order that they were presented so alex wrote a question what are the connections or
disconnections of the dialectical perspectives that you brought up and monism or markovian monism
so can you please repeat this question yeah how do we think about the similarities and dissimilarities of the dialectical
perspectives that you addressed and markovian monism like kind of marco
blanket everything yes so i have recently
come across a couple of works claiming mccoffee and monism
i think from vania vise and colleagues and half prisoner
but unfortunately to be honest i haven't had the opportunity yet to go through this kind of accounts in order to draw
the similarities but i can tell you for example our approach serves a lot of
commonalities for example with work of maxwell ramstadt for example
and colleagues who have argued in favor of a multi-scale
nested markov blankets [Music]
processes um so our our account sells commonalities with such kind of
multi-scale approaches i'm not sure if uh work also again goes
through this kind of directions perhaps one
one difference might be that in our case we don't
take the predictive processing active inference account strictly autologically
but we use it as a tool in order to model and capture specific parts of the
of the process so we don't necessarily presuppose a
nested markov blankets in reality but we
still view them as a very useful way of integrating
this kind of processes formally nice that really maps to the um realism
instrumentalism discussion we've been having uh in these uh discussions so
here's another question from sasha she wrote what activities or mental states
are amenable to creating interpersonal attunement for adults
what kind of activities what kind of activities what kind of uh improvisational or or synchronous or
you're studying it in a very specific case but as far as just our day-to-day life what kind of activities do you
think create that sort of interpersonal achievement for adults okay yeah so
um as we saw in the presentation i gave a simple
example of interpersonal human just between a caregiver and a child in order
to stress how this kind of interpersonal achievement is crucial
not just about our interpersonal achievement but also about survival so we are we cannot escape i am actually
interpersonal at human because otherwise we don't exist neither biologically but not even as
humans so what whatever we learn from language and symbolic functions comes
from developmentally acquired knowledge and which has been of course
being possible through largest larger evolutionary scales but after we gather
this kind of capacities i think here actually another important
point is that i feel that certain paradigms in the past
have been helpful but also misconstitute certain
human functioning as starting taking for example processes theory of
mind as a given stat statically so and then try to
interrogate how this kind of theory of mind process play out in interactions so we see here
that if we take a more historical developmental approach we see that
of course one feedback to the other the individual level to the collective but we see here a primacy
in a regards can way privacy of the collective level so first
we are in tune with others and then we build ourselves and in the adult
life i believe social interaction itself and the experience of the other is what can allow us to
attune to others in different in many different levels for example as
i said before in isolated places that people didn't have the chance to communicate with others might
in them if one you you want to use a bayesian terminology they might develop
so strict priors in terms of their social expectations but when they face other people
from other places um they're unable to turn their beliefs and
one like here just freely speaking for example uh in in this case of so
strictly formed beliefs people might face such a tremendous difficulty
in updating like they need to use so much energy to update their prior prior beliefs that they formed across
development which might even
escape to other malicious strategies in order to confirm their the
inner expectations to the outer world even by for example violence or even killing
exterminating the other because they cannot just wrap their minds around
the existence of other the manifestation of other types of
belief systems for example as you can see in history for example a lot of times when
people from different belief systems or um
or even um different uh [Music] economic interests
clash together and we see that many times instead of being able to adapt to each
other people were violent to each other so i think the key here is early aids exposure to
various forms of life and and beliefs
so that naturally organically people can attune to each other i think as with other processes like language there
might even be maybe more liberal but still a window of this kind of for a human so i think we
are more open for a tuning with others in the world in an earlier age than later but
still um through experience and
both through educating ourselves for example but more
crucially such an approach would even go further suggesting that individual
training is not enough like even if we try to educate ourselves
and and realize that we have acquired biases
against other people this might not be enough even to
eliminate all implicit biases and perhaps only in in real practice in in
the practice of real time social interaction this this these models if you want them can be revealed
really important points thanks for sharing that another question in the chat from steven
is is there a hypothesis that people on the autistic spectrum exhibit different
traits due to perception and action dynamics being different rather than for example just the brain structures
limiting their generative model can you please repeat the question one more time so there's some notes yeah is
there a hypothesis that people on the autism spectrum exhibit different traits due to their perception and action
dynamics being different rather than just their brain structures being different
can you hear me yeah sorry but i'm sorry but i'm losing connection uh at certain points
i can hear you perhaps perhaps my internet connection is not full how
about just if you could reload on your page um how can i access that
just hit the reload on your browser on the window
nice
yep yep sound good good now i think i'm seeing you better
and hear you better could you please repeat the last question great the last question was is there any um hypothesis
that people on the autism spectrum have different traits due to their perception and action dynamics being different
rather than just brain differences so if i understood correctly i
disconnected my camera so that i can maybe i can hear better the sound if i understand
correctly is that whether autistic people might differ
not only in terms of brain function but also
action and perceptual styles yes yeah yeah yeah this is exactly this
exactly what our hypothesis that is touching upon
it argues that people autistic people and other so-called neurotypical people
might differ across different levels of description from brain function to
um to the way that they generate expectations especially about the social
world and to the way that express these expectations
especially about others so grounded in individual accounts of predictive processing and active
inference we argue here that um and in taking predictive processing
and active inference as our two main pillars we um
see here that when you confirm two systems that entertain completely different not
completely but different styles of
generating and expressing social expectations this might create a mishearment
situation where these styles if
left spontaneous spontaneously evolve in a more and more divergent
[Music] situation so starting from
simply taking the precision of dating in single brains we can reach to through
predictive crossing to um generating of social expectations about others to and through active
inference to the way we generate or express or express these expectations
through actions to others and especially when we take into account the other also we see how the similarity of the
similarity of these ways can contribute
in different scenarios so for example um
borrowing the terminology of dynamical systems for example one can see how this how the how taking into
uh how considering this diade one system how this system can
evolve very differently when even when a small mismatch is
up is present in the beginning of of an interaction
thanks and it just sort of uh cracked me up because we're almost replicating your
experiment we're having a mediated dialectic a dialogue and then now you
can see me but i can't see your face and then there's even another level of
the affordance with our friends and colleagues who can ask us questions and it's like everybody has their own
perspective every question is coming to the top of the mind for someone and then it's through that interaction
that we're who we are as individuals and as a lab so just really you know cool to
hear how you brought complexity science and all these different world knowledge tradition
together to also address like very very prescient social issues so another question from
the chat yvonne asks how can i be sure that someone else's social beliefs are actually the same as
mine how can i believe how can we how can i be sure that someone's social beliefs
are the same as mine oh okay yeah so for that um
i guess you can you can never be sure um like this exactly the old bayesian
framework also that's the beauty also i think that we don't uh necessarily dichotomize uh beliefs between for
example who are not true but we place on our beliefs different levels of um
different levels of confidence or precision and like
in a recent collaboration with some colleagues as a
leo christophe moore we examine conceptually the
problem of trust and there we argue for example that trust interpersonal trust is a
is fundamental in this kind of relationships so um based on our
belief of predictability of the other inconsistency and
also that the other would like to treat as well so on a belief of belovedance and also on
shared values so we just accept that we have certain values with some certain people based on these three
points we argue that the people should necessarily entertain trust um about others in
social interactions in order to make our um to make our
social interaction uh functioning well we in fact argue with leo christophe
moore that this is inescapable
practice in real life social interactions because just because we are not able to
track and monitor every possible incident around in in our world so
the next possibility is just to get paranoid and try to to control and monitor the behavior of
everybody in order to have access to everybody's beliefs and actions uh but instead of that i think we um as
humans the trust which of course sometimes is we argue that's always crucial like
already from hundreds gathering um from ancient societies like from
tomatillo work we see how people based on trust they were able to hunt
more complex in more complex scenarios and provide to for themselves
the means to survive in ecological crisis and but we also
argue that the trust also can go wrong in certain times and of course in this in these cases in a
betrayal of trust the whole the whole consequence can be dramatic
both in individual and social level so this this work where uh
leo christophe moyes the first of uh author will publish soon in a
book chapter cool um really nice point about the trust and
the sense making we you know you're giving sentence after sentence i just have to trust you it just and anything
cognitively that demands more than just simply trusting you is just not gonna work so here's a question from laura in
the chat laura writes thank you dr bolas i would like to know if it would be necessary to standardize
the individuals from different cultures conform composing a dyad to avoid
distractors when you evaluate the interaction so how do we think about culture and the dyad how do we control
or explore that yes so our hypothesis um
would go beyond like we used autism as a paradigm example but goal goes beyond
that and how it could accommodate any
um cultural or difference or difference in beliefs
in a simple way like i said for example deploying a diet structure where we have
homogeneous structure diet structure for example people of the same
a culture and people from the same b culture and mixed for example groups and
see how different processes play out and then we
can tease apart at least a certain extent which processes
are out within specific uh cultures or with what process might
emerge out of just out of the communication of between cultures and then we can maybe see how
how the meeting of cultures can provide new possibilities for example and just culture is just one
aspect um in my mind also a socio-economic background is also of
huge importance so people also don't differ only in cultural practices but they differ a lot
in their socioeconomic background and their intentions and motivations so
some people try to change certain aspects of their
socioeconomic needs because they are not satisfied um and even in the level that they
cannot survive as a as a group other people try to preserve and maintain certain um um
socio-economic context contexts so i think it's a very very diverse like um
even in our case that we studied uh the similarity of autistic traits i consider it as oversimplification
we found some inter-relationship in friendship quality but still that's that's just one factor
i think there are so many factors play play out in in the personal achievement
which is good to try to isolate certain aspects but i think at the end of the
day we should try to make to see the big picture in real life
it's almost like um the ancients and their different concepts of friendship different kinds of friendship or different words for friendship and so
quality is going to be a multi-dimensional attribute so tad asks the question
one thing that humans seem to excel at is successfully interacting with complete strangers people we have not
yet had time to attune to how does your approach explain or address this
yes so as i said like in the personal human in the early development i think and attachment
theories are very important here so i think that we are embedded from day one to the social net
social cultural net of our world and that's why we are able to communicate with a
complete stranger because just simply because we both acquired common knowledge
this can be language for example so it we can still communicate with
an animal for example with our dog
but less successfully usually done with other humans but also you see how
dogs and humans also came closer across evolution and we are more because we gain common ground here and we are more
able to communicate so imagine other type of animals more wild animals we
usually we are more difficult to communicate and make sense of these animals but here again trust i think
it's very important just we grew up in completely different places let's say
with completely different people but and we don't know how each other
grew up so but just by sharing common values and
and common ground and just by being able to trust others this
can make instruction functioning like when for example people of different cultures um invaded
other places that they see for the first time people we saw atrocities for example because people didn't trust
the people that they met or they have of course other interests but we see that when we meet an unknown
person of course both possibilities are open we can be kind and functioning we can be also
very vicious i mean as a human species across our history yep it's it's
interesting how you brought up the incentives and the intentions almost separately because there's situations
that could be win-win but then the communication or the narrative breaks down and then there's atrocity or there
are cases when actually the game theory is set up adversarially um and then it
also reminds me of um like our embodied and encultured uh nature as humans what
we share even when we don't share language like when i've been traveling and not spoken the language i'll see
some street food and it's like it's you can communicate with your body and with your actions that you think it
looks like great food or that you want the food and so it's like everyone tastes you know same taste molecules
maybe it's a preference culturally whether it's spicy or sweet but then that's still like
a communication and an interaction and an attunement that is with money that one person is not familiar with a language and a
context so that's really nice i'll ask one more question or is that
cool yes yes sure well okay two more questions the first one is where does
active inference come into play or where do you see active inference being able to sort of meet this very large
philosophical tradition that you're bringing here yeah so
um as we saw in the in the beginning of the presentation um i i see
active interface and predictive processing as um as let's say
the electrical interplay of two strategies has suggested from confusion with other people before as a
an interplay for making sense of the and acting above the world
in order for us to survive so i see active inference as the is the
the active possibility we have in order to maintain our living form so
not just by conforming with the environment but changing the environment
and i found this very neat in this what i find very neat in this account is that we can with the same
terminology we can account for both perceptual learning
process and active action so we see how our perception learning induction
becomes just one whole process that's why i see them as a the electrical phenomenon
they are in ins inseparable and what i tried when i started studying these
processes um some eight uh nine years ago
um in zurich with classic stefan this completely transformed the way i
see even the world myself but but they gradually start feeling
that just by focusing on individual processes or even
both active inference and predictive processing might limit our scope of interpretation so
this exactly with my in my phd i tried to bring together different
different philosophical or scientific frameworks
to try to embed this kind of accounts in a more sociocultural
real life context so in this in this effort for example also
ecological and active approaches that i referred are instrumental also so
um so i i can i i would like to see in the future
um a fusion of philosophical approaches that they see the wholeness of the real life phenomena
such as dialectics with more uh formal ways of interpreting data such as active
inference and also more ecological and active approach and complexity approach such as
dynamical system in in one in one story and see as i say for example one one way
i have seen this happening is that like simply perhaps in one paper of ours we
suggested that we that um bringing together dialectics and then
activisms with active inference we can still keep our emphasis on social interactions
and the embeddedness of organisms in the social world but
also also using powerful computational tools to examine
the individual brains which are embedded in the system so i think an extension of
this kind of active inference accounts perhaps through works such as chris mattis and
zandomizo where if they have proposed two-level metabase and approaches where
by by deploying this they have they suggested this kind of frameworks for studying both learning
and decision making in two levels we have suggested that we can reappropriate this kind of models for
studying individual brains and collective action on this in the same model and these
two our suggestions here that these two levels might not even entertain same
mechanisms so in in the brain we might have a
certain way of minimize prediction error and keep a consistent form in social
interactions between people might have different mechanisms that might have been described more efficiently with an
activist account for example or dynamical systems but i think by bringing together these tools
more complete picture of both the sociological
processes and the actual mechanisms at the biological level might and how this
feedback uh to one another might become more apparent
wow you know i was gonna ask what the next research steps were that was quite an agenda i mean it's really
awesome um maybe just on a closing question no what would you um
like to just close with or where are we gonna go from here what are your next research steps or what are you excited
to see the community be looking into yeah yes i just mentioned i would be
very excited to see this kind of uh school of thoughts coming more closely
together i think more and more people are working lately on this bringing insights of uh
of more social interactional approaches and more
formal brain approaches together and also philosophy and practice i think it's
very important here as because you always argue that
like a fact is data are not never
objective um in fact so as soon as we gather specific data
already we imply theory so only the way we deploy like i think philosophy is
very important here to to form new experiments and new models
not only for interpreting um data and also this is from the research part
but also practice is very important um so i would like really this kind of approaches to
be used in practice in real life for example in
psychiatry is one domain where we can re-examine more holistically certain
conditions for example in the past we had more sociological more
like social psychiatry examined also the external factors uh of like the impact of society in
specific conditions and later we had more cognitive model where in biological genetic models where
we try to identify redefine psychiatric condition based on the
genetics or cognitive abilities i'll be very happy to see now
these two coming together and one informs the other so a more evidence-based um
holistic sociological approach in in concrete concrete
applications of social policy such as psychiatry education
and other associated domains wow very cool so
thanks a lot for joining this guest stream too it was really a great discussion and really we're looking
forward to seeing what happens with this line of research and hopefully talking to you and colleagues at future times so
we'll certainly see you around thank you very much for inviting and thank you very much for your great
initiative in providing these seminars which are very illuminating so far awesome talk to you
later meet you again so bye